. Hey, this is very interesting.
We've been thinking out loud what is going
to be the landing spot for lots of former
Trump administration officials and one of
the former administration officials that as
the Trump administration was winding down,
I said this person deserves this person should
be on hirable for the degree of dishonesty
and humiliation that they participated in
during the Trump administration.
I was talking about one of Donald Trump's
former press secretaries, Kayleigh McEnany,
and we sort of said maybe she'll do some kind
of communication or consulting for some right
wing group.
Maybe she'll become a pundit or go back to
being a pundit or something like that.
Screw the Citizens for Ethics Watch Citizens
for Ethics.
Africa with the W stands for Citizens for
Ethics.
I think watch.
They found a they found in Kayleigh McEnany
financial disclosures, an indication that
Caylee had a gig lined up with Fox News.
And of course, that would not be in any way
surprising to us.
There is a sort of revolving door, in fact,
between Fox News and the Trump administration.
Trump often even thinking of hiring people
after seeing them on Fox News.
This document was exposed and it was revealed
that Kayleigh McEnany reached an agreement
with Fox News to start working there this
month.
However, after this was revealed, there was
a statement put out by Fox News saying simply,
Kayleigh McEnany is not currently an employee
or contributor at Fox News.
What may have happened here and at this point
it is mere speculation, is that while the
agreement was in place early in January for
Caylee to start at Fox News, the January 6th
riots and just the disaster that ended up
being the final days of the Trump administration
made Fox rethink, at least temporarily, this
deal.
And while I think it is completely plausible
that in a month and two months and six months,
who knows?
Kayleigh McEnany is going to show up as a
contributor on Fox News.
It seems maybe they have just paused it in
their deciding to delay this.
And if you look at the very carefully worded
statement from Fox News, again, their only
statement was Kayleigh McEnany is not currently
an employee or contributor at Fox News.
It seems as though they are choosing to delay
that.
Now, there were also other really interesting
things in Kayleigh McEnany financial disclosure.
One is that the on campus right wing group,
Turning Point USA, which is Charlie Kirk,
is the guy who's known to be the sort of public
facing figure of that organization.
Turning Point USA paid for a 65 hundred dollar
gift for Caylee and a guest to go to an event
in which she received an award.
In December, Caylee went to the winter gala
at Mar a Lago.
And there were obviously questions about what
there's a there's a pandemic.
What the hell are they doing?
She was given an award by Turning Point USA
at Trump's Mar a Lago, and she was given a
6500 dollar gift.
She also reported receiving close to two hundred
thousand dollars in salary and bonus from
the Trump campaign and RNC.
And that includes a few months before she
started working at the White House.
But it is reported that she was still getting
paid twelve thousand dollars or more by the
campaign after working at the White House
campaign employee government employee same
time while getting gifts from Turning Point
USA and making deals with Fox News while still
the press secretary of the United States.
It's wacky stuff.
I don't think any of us will find this to
be even remotely surprising.
If we were wondering about the trajectory
on Fox News for the next couple of years,
hiring one of the biggest Trump liars and
sycophants hints to me that they're not planning
on getting away from the Trump stuff.
They in fact, they may Fox News may have to
go more pro Trump in order to compete with
on a Newsmax.
Remember that in the aftermath of Trump not
being able to steal the election from Joe
Biden, many Fox News.
Yours abandoned Fox News and went over to
Oakland and or Newsmax, and this is a real
issue for Fox News, if they believe that they
need to go more Trumpy to maintain or regain
their audience.
Where do the traditional conservatives go?
Not that I care, but I am certainly curious
about that.
And if Republicans learn nothing from Trump
and move further in the Trump direction, do
the traditional Republicans become centrist
Democrats?
I'm genuinely unsure.
I don't feel bad for them.
The traditional Republicans, starting with
Ronald Reagan in the 1980s, going to Newt
Gingrich in the 1990s, they benefited from
the same anti intellectual ism that led to
Trump.
So I don't feel bad for them at all.
It's merely a curiosity.
Where do they go?
If Fox News goes for Trump?
For now, Kayleigh McEnany will not be joining
Fox News.